so in a few moments were going to
tradition we're going to go into the
locked section of the graveyard this is
called the Covenanters prison so I
provided you and beyond the gate I'm
going to take you inside one of the two
it's called the black mausoleum our mark
is where all the poltergeist activity
takes place but before we go into you
I've got lots of things any control
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we're back it's episode 31 31
rolling off episode 31
what's this episode I should do like you
know what I should do I should do like
you don't remember how like this is how
old we are remember back in the old days
when Casey Kasem had the top 40 not and
look he was on the radio and like every
time like a number came up and stuff
like that baby number 75 so it's like
this I feel like I should start doing
that now there but everyone listening is
like please don't do it why don't we
please don't do that I'm not gonna
biggest record okay anyway this is
episode 31 yo and well we did kind of a
couple of unpleasant shows the last
couple weeks you know necrophile serial
killers whatnot
this one is a little more fun I guess
well sort of probably not for the people
involved but you know it's kind of more
of a fun paranormally type of chopping
them yet what to call some what what
they know what the name of this damn
don't be a douche man well one minute it
okay what's what's this one about
we are going to talk about Greyfriars
kirkyard in edinburgh scotland the most
haunted cemetery in scotland
specifically we're going to talk about
the entity or whatever it is called the
McKenzie poltergeist okay and you wrote
about this for the new book that's
coming out right dozen cases right yes
that's yeah that's another thing all
right so yeah my new book will be out
soon the print version is done the eBook
version is done I'm just working on
recording the audio version and I think
I mentioned it before but it's called
the unseen hand yeah and it has like
over over a hundred like poltergeist
type cases right and bitcoin is actually
in there right a couple yeah that's a
huge book it's like 400 some pages you
know that's it that's the print version
so this is like big old fat book sigil
book fan book now poltergeist should be
a good one is people going to like this
one
yeah all right before beginning this
let's talk about what's been going on on
the podcast because the podcast has been
exploding the past couple weeks yes we
went from like a thousand total
downloads on that thing and in a period
of about a couple weeks for them like
five thousand
yeah that downloads out of them yeah our
downloads double they like double the
junk from last month and they're
probably on that they almost look like
they're in line just possibly triple it
almost looks like exponential growth yes
what you have them and of course that's
uh because of our mom yes yeah my mom's
really doing a really good job with the
project entertainer wearing them yeah
yeah arm shout-out to Armand Rosa Mellie
we don't like to shout out all the other
podcasters because turns out the
evidently according to Amon they're all
listen to our show would be very funny
because when we first started this yeah
I mean like he said we kind of started
it when we met or Monde and we kind of
started it like sort of as a lark yeah
and I was like no one's get a listeners
rapid rambling we made it a book saying
yeah I'm on my mom want to tell people
who are mom did yeah our mother is
Amelia he does the arm cast podcast news
on a few other he's a horror writer
around well-known yeah and we met him at
a book signing at gods and monsters here
in Orlando big meiotic bookstore and
he's a super cool guys yeah we got along
with a real world event man you know
what you guys need to be on the podcast
you know an ingénue invited us on so
this is it and we you know we were like
yeah well you know if we do it we're
going to do a good job but we don't
really care if it in comes of it [__]
that's how things began yeah you can
become you know you have to start
somewhere
yeah and then you know kind of taken off
that's pretty neat it's funny though you
know because you could tell the
demographics are very different it's
very different if you look on our
YouTube show on our YouTube channel art
there are shows that had guests like dr.
Robert price and the AGP the hits on
those are fantastic some of them you
know they have like 6,000 views on some
of them I think one was approaching
5,000 the other one I think is
approaching 6,000 and you know it sounds
like a lot but then if you go to the art
podcast numbers yeah the audio pod yeah
those I don't understand those shows are
just the same as all the other shows
it's kind of it's weird you can see yeah
it's two different demographics I think
runs those people that listen to us on
YouTube and the people that listen to us
on project entertainment it really seems
like which is kind of good it's kind of
why we sort of go all over the place
like with the topics I mean we don't
know who's listen
there's a bunch of this is a big dip
yeah like I said we don't necessarily
took topics because oh we say people
like that right not you know not usually
we usually just like you know we want to
direct a we are interested in talking
about and then to the American audience
here you know to you guys we look at
what's happening on the podcast of the
demographics who's downloading we got a
lot of them from like Australia and
Ireland ins and turkey turkey and you
know weird like that like we never
expected that yeah we have a pretty big
international audience also yeah which
is already cool right yeah and they seem
to like things that we didn't expect
like things that on YouTube that were
kind of Doug shows yeah went over real
well on podcast yeah like I said you
never really know when everything is no
like I said that's why I don't really
care I just kind of pick a topic at
random and just feel like yeah we can
talk about that from big enough Doug we
did was the UFO show even though that
was one of my favorite I don't know
that's what I see I try to tell you
because see Tom is super into UFOs he
loves you he loves you a friend of some
of the cases no he always wants to watch
like UFO documentaries and stuff like
that I'm like dude that is so boring no
well then I mean some of them are not
boring but most of our same thing is
like I walked outside and I saw a light
in this guy that four hours later I just
woke up and I had my but well I like the
one that not like those of triangles or
the cops yeah they're like Phoenix
lights not the fake Phoenix lights not
the not a fire yeah the other the other
Phoenix like people and you know my mind
just goes like damn what the hell was
that
yeah you know if that was man-made why
would they make something like yeah I
think it's kind of it was the reason
that I'm not as interested in UFOs is
the same reason that I'm not as
interested in Bigfoot because one I
think it's pretty plausible that there's
probably aliens okay well these visited
earth or not you know that's a different
question but you know obviously there's
life somewhere else in the [__]
universe obviously so it's not that
crazy to me what's not paranormal it's
just farther than apples right that's
not it's not paranormal and also tinting
was Bigfoot it's like if there was a
Bigfoot I don't think there is but if
there was it's like big deal it's just a
big monkey or a big hairy personnel
people could tell
paranormal is the spirit that's why we
can't find the tracks anymore so they
just use that to justify yeah well
they're just going that under and also I
would like to I know this is like not
anything to do with the town but I
wasn't in it but know what I was going
to say here it's the funny thing about
what's what's the [__] channel is
that is it discovery or destination
AmeriCorps wears one and it's like you
know how they had the show they had to
show Finding Bigfoot
yeah and now they have one called
generally base but I'm like hey do you
have even finding big but you can't
killing Bigfoot until you're finding it
that fat redneck jumps up you can't kill
big but they're killing people dinner's
got there and what was the other one
were they're diving into the holes is
that she got with everything big Finding
Bigfoot I think that was called there
are so many big ridiculous ridiculous
there yeah we run around making all that
noise of headlights and shotguns we're
looking for a Bigfoot about that well if
there's a Bigfoot to be up in Canada up
Washington State or way down in one of
those natural one one of those national
parks where man is it hasn't sets what
thousands of years maybe there's
something like a Bigfoot but I kind of
doubt yeah I think they'd have found it
by now
yeah they would have yeah expresses any
mapping if any way I could almost you
okay well before we go I wanted to say
project Entertainment Network go to
their patreon give me a buck or two also
we are probably going to start a patreon
or forgot about it at some point into
the next few months whenever I get
around to doing it will probably make an
official announcement video when we do a
patreon yeah it's probably a very simple
patreon where you know you can donate 5
10 15 or 20 or something like that what
I'm going to do it by units like there's
a bunch of different ways so they can
say I would just do it like five dances
yeah it'll just be some simple [__] yeah
and you guys can play whatever you want
this geek show role and you don't give
us incentive to keep making these things
yeah even though we just don't
so anyways okay god we just took a blood
dollar offer you know eight-hour day
that seems like eight hours so anyway
okay so to talk of today we were talking
about Greyfriars kirkyard
yeah heard of this one in Edinburgh
Scotland and like I said I wrote about
this in my book was specifically the
poltergeist but it's actually kind of an
interesting you know place other than
that but um it was actually established
1500s the reason it's called Greyfriars
is because there used to be a Priory
there are a Priory rather and the friars
wore a room so they were in a row yes so
like so after that was dissolved in 1559
then they put the churchyard there now
great fires is also I just thought I
would mention this because it's kind of
a cute story if you've heard the story
of Greyfriars Bobby he is the little sky
carrier who was owned by it could be
it was either a policeman or could have
been a farmer they're not really sure as
it was John Gray and he had this little
dog and the dog apparently after his
owner died he like sat on the dog and on
his owners grave for like he came back
and said on the Eldersburg felt like 14
years until he died himself and then
they buried him in the inn Greyfriars
kirkyard and now there's like a little
statue of him okay it's like a little
statue of him like on top of there's
like a water fountain for people and
then at the bottom there's a little
water fountain for dogs okay
but it's but it said to this and not to
[__] on anyone's cheerios or anything
because because there's so there's like
a big thing about the most loyal dog in
Scotland and why can't people be that
loyal and stuff like that but a lot of
naysayers say that oh well it wasn't the
same dog there are a lot of stray dog
dog that lived in the graveyard if
people would feed them so they stay
there and then little bit of stories
yeah so this story kind of built up
around it so you know I don't know if
that's true but Greyfriars Bobby there's
a little statue of him there okay okay
so what we're going to talk about mostly
is the black mausoleum already sounded
good it's already sounding good yeah the
black mausoleum now the black mausoleum
is the tomb of a person named Sir George
McKenzie all right now he was in the
17th century he was a judge and Lord
advocate and he was put in power by king
charles ii in scotland to this day he is
still known as bloody mckenzie no and
the reason he is known as bloody
mckenzie was because in the late 1600s
apparently there was this big schism
where it was like a big religious schism
right it's like the the King wanted
everyone to be I believe it was was it a
Episcopalian right because that was
going to be the the official Church
religion and then there was this big
group of people called the covenant
earth so-called because they would not
sign the Covenant to become Episcopalian
because they were Presbyterian Lugar and
they were horribly prosecuted prosecutor
/ persecuted persecuted like I said and
prosecuted all the I guess kind of right
because they refused to sign and they
wouldn't give up their beliefs now there
was a huge battle in 1679 and a bunch of
the Covenant heirs were captured it was
called the Battle of Bothwell bridge
3,000 of them were captured and they
were brought to Greyfriars kirkyard by
bloody McKenzie where he hanged some of
them he beheaded some of them and put
their heads up on pikes so everyone
could see it
he also tortured a bunch of them and
some of them went free but some of them
were imprisoned and stuff like that so
there's this big this big area of the
kirkyard is now called covenant or
prison it was basically like a big open
air it was like a concentration camp
right basically is what I want enough
what's that what is there between
Episcopalian and oppressed okay so now
see that was another thing that I was
going to say it was really there doesn't
seem like difference to me there does
back it was a big deal I guess it was a
big deal I'm not actually sure with the
differences if price it the way they
interpreted the word yeah well that's
all it ever yes anyway all never is but
so some of the common is there's like I
said most when were killed horribly
tortured some were put on a boat shipped
off to Australia over the time that this
Lord Advocate Sir George McKenzie was in
power they estimates that he killed
Corvis was responsible for the death of
18,000
of these people religious dissenters and
okay 18,000 this is just a slight
skirmish this is actually a civil war
but yeah boy yes yes and they still in
Scotland still to this day they refer to
that period as the killing time right
and it's funny because it seems like
from by all accounts this Sir George
Mackenzie person and you know if you see
like I'll put a picture of them in the
YouTube video but he just looks like you
know a 16th 17th century do with his wig
and everything like that but they said
that he was actually you know he's a
normal person he had a family he was
like you know real smart II wrote books
and all another kind of [__] but still
did really really did not like those
prints appareance
I bet there was more to it than just
religion now I'm going to do his land
and money as usual well it usually does
that family money anyone in politics who
was trying to get on the throne probably
all kind of stuff like that yeah well
sure yeah never just were losers yeah so
you know so this dude killed 18,000
people right he died and they bury him
and Greyfriars kirkyard he has a
beautiful it's and it's actually quite a
beautiful tomb
like I said the black model and
ironically many of the Covenant errs
that he killed are also buried right
near there whether they're kind of
pissed off in the Astro now is that is
it black or they just call it like um
it's hard it like in some pictures it
does look black okay try it dark grey or
something yeah it's good you know so it
does look black in some pictures but
then in some pictures in bright daylight
it just looks gray okay but so this tomb
sat quietly from you know the 17th
century until 1998 in 1998 so the story
goes a homeless man was in the cemetery
and he was either now some stories have
it you know oh there was a bad storm and
he was looking for shelter
so he decided to break into a mausoleum
because like you do
Brooks or that he was just you know
looking for stuff to steal yeah like
looking looking to loot a tomb
alright so he
breaks into the black mausoleum because
it has these doors on it with this like
kind of greeting on the front he breaks
in there and he's fiddle [__] around
what no ok I'm saying he's gonna say the
eyes it kind of looks like a tomb on the
cover
Judas Priest in a percent out see our
honourable what that looks like now I'm
gonna have to go look down so I can head
better go
yeah oh yeah yeah you're right it might
do it well I've got any kind of it kind
of looking with the same on no thank you
okay well maybe it's the same desk how's
that ever yeah okay so this homeless man
he breaks into the tomb right and then
he starts fiddle [__] around saying
hey maybe there's some like valuables in
somebody's caught oh yeah he decided to
become a grave robber
yeah why not now we're back to grave
robbing again he wasn't having sex with
any of the books as though that we know
and knock it off he so he breaks it up
oh so he breaks and feels like some of
the coffins and stuff like that now
while he's breaking into some of the
coffins he either falls in a pit behind
him that he didn't see or he crashes
through the floor so the town dressed to
do is yeah it's like it's two or three
levels down is what it is okay how could
the part that I understand you've got a
mausoleum how could there be levels
below it how does that work out what is
this happening again is that over time
like oh like I said when years past like
should you bury people under there and
they said oh we're going to build a
bubble on top of that okay and then you
know what I mean alright should happen
alright so it wasn't part of the initial
plan of the mausoleum it just had like
it was initially planned to be like a
triple decker now well evidently not
because when this homeless man crashed
through the floor he fell into an
unknown I didn't previously unrecorded
pit where evidently they had learned a
bunch of plague victims back in the day
before the mausoleum was built okay and
accounts differ now some say that he
fell in the pit and it was like because
the pit had been sealed off that the
bodies weren't entirely like
partly mummified and like some of them
people had hair and like ragged clothing
and they built stumps like this still
smelled like and debt and it was endemic
or how long is 500 years yeah nothing
like that
so then you said it was like all slimy
and gross yeah and I mean you know even
if I don't want to have reason even if
it wasn't that still be pretty upsetting
they didn't follow Fitness just full of
skeletons and Chim you just be like
poltergeist when she felt like a pole
outside I would think after 500 years as
a pond it'd be tough so one day you
would think that when you and especially
I don't know though maybe it's kind of
like you know like there was [__] one
of those like mummies that fall into bog
lists involved people that maybe it was
that kind of thing I don't know are
there any photos of this I don't know I
found photos in a hole you downloaded to
the hole yeah and you okay so then it
happened and I some and I did find one
picture like when I was looking around
like researching this I did find one
picture and it looked like kind of a
hole and then there were like some like
a bunch of bones and skeletons but I'm
not sure if that was the exact looking
at my bit that may have not have been
that might have been another - that's a
graveyard because it was just tagged
with that huh
he with that Gregory we're not sure so
we're not sure okay but evidently so
this guy fell in this hole he hold on
well it's not too excited to see the
photo yeah how far down is it - you
can't Malky the bump okay yeah no I'm
just saying I'm just telling with the
legend is just like what legend is if it
maybe it happened on all right so this
one look guys falls in this pit full of
other way well I guess maybe I have you
don't know there was no way to find out
this is what this is what well I'll get
that okay your visit alright so there's
almost got Falls with it there's dead
bodies in there now he jumped out of the
pit understandably and goes tear it off
into the night meanwhile there's a
security guard walking around the
kirkegaard with his dog huh and he's
like what's all that noise coming from
that mausoleum over there so he goes
over to check it out and sees this
homeless man tearing ass out of this
mausoleum okay looking like [__] because
I guess he fell on me so why me or
safety or whatever not and he's like
writing like oh my god
I'm done as a cemetary never could be
see again okay it's not in Lenin dear
express down and mystic no yeah then
like according to account the security
guard quit the next day that also sounds
yes gives me but now not all accounts a
doesn't some day because they say he's
like I quit in this tale or at least I
don't know if he thought the homeless
guy was a go did was this is what this
is what's striking me about it in this
version of the legend both primary
witnesses are not available they're gone
yeah see that's problematic to me but
it's a good story call let's go yeah
what happened okay so apparently the
security guys see this guy right he
quits the next day or whatever to rip
off this night I have to bathe man
another complaint about it or go ahead
okay one all right you can't weaken your
boy we just ha ha ha we can't hear that
- and then I can just delete it
alright so it might as well have not
happen no here's a story thing me
nervous good why is it making me nervous
I don't know no I swear to God no one is
going to have sex of a dozen I just have
to keep bugging you about it because
it's been funny that you get to know
uncomfortable that hilarious way okay so
so like I said before this homeless man
fell into this pit no one evidently had
ever reported any paranormal activity
around this particular - but even though
its occupant was one of the most reviled
historical figures and Scottish history
however it's said that the somewhat
further by knocking all on the floor
unleashed some type of I don't know what
psyche broke down through the doorway
down into the gates of hell it's pretty
much like that that's already looks like
that okay and since we're coming up to
the halfway point already
yes more or less okay so I'm going to
take a break now and then after the
break we'll talk about what maybe got
unleashed by this poor man falling to
the floor
Fievel yeah actor would like to see a
photograph of that well I'll see if I
can file but I couldn't really find one
alright alright so we're gonna I'm
getting suspicious
was this video some of us some about
this a really good job at this one
okay well understand I'm telling you
what's different it's a story it's a
good sorry it's a good story and like I
said it's in my book and I want to
reserve my judgment
yeah and reserve much don't get all them
go I'm like independence okay
I'm gonna bring up necrophilia I go I
get that way too
alright alright so we're going to take a
break right now we'll be back in just a
minute ladies and gentlemen project
Entertainment Network presenters
applause the mentor is the greatest
manager of all time mando Guerrero parts
unknown open coming superstar look right
tell me I'm not going to keep summer
camp and check out it right off [__]
MIDI you two are a legend or dysentery
mi dragon can attain an antler
subculture courses in clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing checkout
subculture online at subculture corsets
calm that's subculture corsets calm make
sure you use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount subculture
corsets calm or visit their store in
Jacksonville Florida just off i-95 watch
out there's a new tailor taking over
kitchens around the world
thrills chills mad cooking skills it
cooks a weekly podcast coming with
recipe tips food five seasonal specials
and guests galore hosted by horror
author amber Fallon hey that's me
a foodie was over 20 years of experience
cooking baking and generally making a
nuisance of herself
you watched Food Network you've read
cookbook but nothing can prepare you for
it cook coming to a device near you
hallo sir
graphic design by Jenny Ashton
specializing in posters and flyers
special rate for fans at heart
quick turnaround time
book and CD covers
consultations through email or Skype
logos and packaging
payment through PayPal
as in problem material
satisfaction guaranteed visit the
Facebook page of Hollow Earth design or
email pecking ate at pot real calm
[Music]
all right we're back okay so how much
guy falls through the pit of the black
mausoleum once belonging to Sir George
Mackenzie bit of a bastard
as the English would say and pretty much
now it was either the next day or two
days after this alleged incident a woman
was asked the cemetery and she peeked in
through the little window there on the
door and she claims that a huge cold
wind like knocked her back off her feet
right blowing through a little door
blowing through the little yes you'd be
like it's double doors and there's like
little square yeah with like a little
bit of like iron grating over them now a
couple days after that another woman
shut up another one what am I going to
say to Bonnie what one so we were
watching Star Trek last night yeah
that's I do I never do whenever the ship
gets hit by something and they all start
rolling down one side the other hit kirk
rolling around in the damn chair that's
how that's it man I've heard the badge
and her doing that quim with the wind
blowing the best on and I can't really
watch like did you know a BBC America
like on Friday nights they do like a
bunch of a bunch of old Star Trek and so
like we're watching them I can't remote
it was but holy [__] like one of the red
shirts in that one yeah in the
background he totally did like a really
nice like gymnastic looking slip and
everything lifts over yes he won his
Academy Award I was going to say that
guy's probably like he got home and he's
always mom look that's me
don't appointment background yeah that
giant space amoeba I think one yeah the
entity syndrome or whatever that's
called yeah I think that's the one it
was but yeah watch out for that it was
saying with the light level of his word
so okay so this woman's issues blast off
her feet by like a cold wind or
something pushing her now a couple days
after that another woman was found in
the kirkyard by the tomb unconscious and
she had like strangle marks around her
neck and when she woke up she said that
an invisible person had tried to
strangle her okay and also they found a
man like not the same day but I think it
was you know
same week or whatever they also found a
man unconscious by the tomb
now hold on ones like this okay our
witness is documented that they actually
have these witnesses and their testimony
now the first woman I don't think they
have her name all I'm actually these
first three people I don't think the
other day okay I just have to telling
even a good story yeah this is how a
look will be okay so all these people
started up unconscious around it and
plus like now it was dangerous because
the hole was open and all this other
stuff
so the Enver a City Council says okay
well we're going to block off the
mausoleum and keep the public away from
it until we figure out what's going to
changing now is this part documented did
the City Council actually do this we're
going to be telling us that the city
counted that okay and actually if you
look this to go down on that does lead
there's pictures online of I'm so good
on this thing
yeah you can't though so that makes it
plausible that maybe there was some
problems there yeah there obviously was
something going on because the City
Council did say okay
they've restricted access to okay I'm
gonna give it a couple more points cred
points cred point okay yeah now there
was a local writer in Edinburgh and his
name was John Andrew Henderson and he
petitioned the council he said can I
conduct tours of the mausoleum and they
said he could but they said no you can't
go around the mausoleum unless you're
part of the tour so he started a company
called I think it's called black heart
entertainment or black something like
black art something and he started like
a good like a quote-unquote ghost tour
to show people the mausoleum like I
think they go all around the it's called
the City of the Dead tour so I guess you
can go all around the kerf yard and they
talk about all the different because
there's like a lot of famous like people
buried there and stuff too but um you
know the black mausoleum is kind of the
highlight of it and you can't go to the
black mausoleum unless you're part of
this tour what's the official tour okay
now since that happened like since the
the tour started the website now
the council keeps track of this earth
the website of the tour company keeps
track of this they have reported almost
500 incidents of paranormal activity
most of it violent most of it directed
toward people in the tour group okay
back up who reports dis again different
be almost people on the doors and there
were okay okay so the people from the
tours are reporting are reporting and
they're reporting it to today they
usually report it well they report it to
the tour company like I said the core
company keeps a record and they take
photographs and things like that
so they're not sure like I said I don't
think any paranormal activity was
recorded before they felt it before so
now they're thinking that this guy
following through this is either the
ghost of bloody McKenzie coming back to
[__] with [__] again in life or it's all
the ghosts of the plague victims that
are mad about their sleep interrupted I
know what is actually being reported
okay so here are the things that are
interrupted that are reported most
common reported people blacking out
there have been about almost 200 reports
of that people going unconscious and
they said that happens pretty often on
tours usually at least one personal
blackout okay people report being
scratched or hit and then later on and
there's pictures of it online then
plater on they'll have these strange you
know built their back will be covered
with scratches or their arms will be
covered with scratches or they'll have
burn marks and sometimes they show up
while they're still in the tour
sometimes they don't show up until
afterwards
this is kind of subjective right and
could shake yeah but I'm not saying it
didn't happen just keep that in mind
yeah I mean people also have reported
strange noises knocking growling
laughter people report of fires noqreh
fires where um these details on that
well here is the thing the guy that runs
the the tour the Henderson person now he
later wrote a book about about the
McKenzie poltergeist I think it was
called the ghosts that haunted itself
because he lived across the street from
the cemetery for a while so he's done it
kind of got interested in it it should
be noted that his house and the tour
offices burned down mysteriously like
apparently the insurance investigators
couldn't find any cause from them maybe
those insurance where I've got caught
yeah that's exactly should know how that
is you know yeah so like another thing
that people report to they report like
like pieces their skin being gouged out
huh you know but other than you know
bruises stuff like that and a lot of
people say they feel nauseated you know
that's subjective that's subjective also
sorry Burke does breakers also um dead
animals are often found around the tomb
like in larger numbers than you would
expect ones I also evidently there are
four houses very close to the cemetery
like around the cemetery that have also
reported poltergeist activity in the
form of small fires object a portation
and you know dishes and ship flying
around no good so they're not super sure
I don't know how true the story is about
the homeless man falling when we could
be only like no one named homeless man
obviously he never turned up again right
and in every you know in every source of
the story you know since the security
guard saw him and freaked out some of
them say he quit the next day but none
of them could give a name yeah that's
suspicious and let me ask you this is
there any record of them repairing the
floor inside that model yeah see I don't
know about that I mean obviously
something weird happened there or there
was something going on around there I
don't know if it was vandals or
something like that because the city
council did intervene and they said
people you know they don't want people
to go around it anymore
all the stuff that's being reported
around this tour to me is kind of
suspicious everything kind of sounds
like they would be in the tour the tours
advantage for that kind of stuff that I
write and see dinosaurian what happens
you know you find dead animals let's
take them down to where the tour is and
throw those down in there yet I mean
maybe we'll have a buddy hide hide
behind this tombstone make it how or
laughs or the tour goes so that kind of
stuff yeah then maybe the tour doesn't
do that well unless you know I mean
those insurance wires get crossed and
it's on the tour and where the guy lives
burn that down cash you know I'm not
saying I'm just I'm just saying I'm not
the it was just that yeah we'll see and
that's the problem and like I said I ran
into this a lot when I was when I when I
was writing my book of which this is
going to be it's going to be in there
you don't know really I mean and in this
case it does seem like there's a little
bit of a profit motive because yeah this
guy wrote a book about the about the
thing you know he obviously gives tours
and tourists go there and Carroll is
fairly successful this goes toward that
he does and also and I love the Scotland
I love you sir this is so awesome
they have obviously they have like a
little gift shop and very friars
kirkyard and the gift shop is called the
creepy we disco creepy we cuz you know
in Scotland everything is tiny we
emotion so it's creepy we not doing so I
thought it was darling I don't know I
got too much testosterone we find that
darling well that's your problem
it is but um but now some people are
super hardcore about this right oh you
know I'll tell you one thing I would
like to go see this right get a feel for
the place you know I don't want to talk
bad about the guy he's running the tour
I don't want to talk about about this
situation I really I really do you know
I would encourage people to go check it
out yeah just to see yeah yeah I find
I'm sure I'm feeling skeptical but I'd
like to go see it I mean it does seem
like
okay and I've been skeptical before and
I've been wrong yeah skeptical yeah yeah
but actually what I'm still just kind of
hemming on a little bit I need to know
more
yeah I'm interested I mean they're okay
now there are some witness accounts now
this guy who's unnamed he wants to
remain anonymous he was a police officer
okay but he then went on a home and then
not on this police officer
yeah well he was he used to be a bully
Augustus and it's anonymous and he says
he doesn't want his Nieto we can't prove
it right
yeah this is what he said we can't prove
this but this is what we can't through
and he said at this unprovable man right
actually said this so let's see what
this approve of it because okay he's not
a step forward he's anonymous I could
pull an anonymous anything out of my ask
you though right come on
well this is a good series this is what
he said now he went on the tour
right okay he said after the tour I
decided to go back to her hotel room I
was glancing at the ghosts that haunted
itself which was the book about the
McKenzie folder and when I felt a sharp
jab like a lioness you have like a blood
I know when I felt a sharp I lucked out
what I mean
when I felt a sharp burning sensation on
the right side of my neck there weren't
late at least five deep scrapes that
appeared to center of my Adam's apple
I'm returning home the next morning I
went straight to my mother's house and
told her my tale along with handing her
the book which I decided I did not want
in my home and yesterday I phoned her
and asked her what she thought of the
book remarkably she was just examining
five large scratches under her out of
them that were identical to my own I'm
not the sort of individual who frightens
easily but hand on heart I'm very
frightened now the phenomenon you having
that graveyard prison is very real he
says I'm not okay whether this is a real
furnace it does not if you know what
that sounds like a plug for the book I
was going to say that almost kind of
sounds like and if you're a real person
dude I'm sorry but it sounds like you
know how some of those like restaurant
owners will go on Yelp
Ron Yelp and Brighton and get themselves
a really good review like an episode
this is the best restaurant ever and
that work is so scary a lot in our any
odor is so handsome and awesome
Hahnemann I don't know I kind of feel
like it's that guy thing they do warn
you like I have a little bit of there's
videos of it on you here this is not the
SCOTUS the Scottish version of the
Blarney Stone I think it might be the
Scottish version of the Blarney well
it's not while that is the Blarney Sarah
okay but like I gotta test on that blind
stone who does the tour guides and Irish
people yeah I was living in when I was
living in Boston I dated an Irish girl
she told me you know yeah they they make
all the foreigners kiss the Blarney
Stone that night when when tours aren't
there we come out of bar and piss on
this thing totally sounds like something
I would do Irish you're doing that [__]
you know listen they come here to see
their ancestors and all their ancestors
are dead that's hilarious
all the Irish that you're there to see
your ancestors okay so you know if you
ever go to Ireland don't kiss the
Blarney no just approach it right don't
tell them that you're there to see your
ancestors yeah they probably said it
last night you know they're all good oh
my god yeah okay so now here was another
thing also they they also like um a lot
of people reported like weird smells
sulfur that kind of thing like it was
from hell obviously I guess that's why
sulfur now they've also had a couple
people in to do exorcisms a spiritualist
minister named Colin grant so these
would have a name yeah he did an
exorcism now his son did one a year
later neither of them work definitely
but come on I have a go I have a
question and I have a question why would
a profitable tour want to get rid of
their cash cow finally exercising it
away did they do it you know I don't
know it just says exorcisms were
performed in the passive voice okay so
I'm not a shirt like this we won't have
a name for this the thing would the City
Council call in an exorcist I doubt it
notice what an exorcist well maybe an
exorcist would just go there of their
own volition
maybe it happened but
and then they claimed well didn't work
yeah
okay but now this is a good dis isn't
good but this is a good string of
Blarney another letter I never heard God
never going to forget I wouldn't do not
kiss better blonde I wouldn't do that
anyway congest [__] girl alright oh
my god even if people work this thing on
it I'm still not very sanitary I'm not a
but um so Colin grant was a minister and
he did an actress and now some did one a
year later however the first one that
Colin granted he did the exorcism it
didn't work and then a couple like I
don't know how long how soon it was
after that some people said a weeks it
was a two weeks
Colin grant mysteriously died okay of a
heart attack
or they're not really sure why right
there what did this guy actually this is
nothing good I never met the guy okay
I never met the guy so so they don't
know it's like you know the GU step
right that's the only like death really
eyes now when you read are attributed
when you wrote about the case where did
you say it may be is he included in this
is in this part of a story yes yes oh
yes and could you find out whether or
not he actually existed you get to go
back in there before it hits printer
that me does did that I didn't I just go
by sources okay for by the sources said
it yeah okay
several so different sources say
administrative calendar and was
overheated and exorcism and then several
different sources say that it's a week
or two later he was ok now is Sunday
next Justin's doing as far as I know it
sounds a lot so I didn't get him all
right
but um just chicken yeah now so like I
said there are also several houses
around the tomb that have reported
poltergeist activity dishes flying
around and stuff like that and as I
mentioned before the the writer who runs
the tours in 2003 a fire you know pretty
much demolished his house and his
offices and he said that he lost
everything like even all the information
he had about the poltergeist like all
who did that all his [__] oka gone so he
said the only reason
he still had a few things was because he
hasn't filed on a different computer but
he said that um so you know so his house
in office were destroyed and he did not
want to be civil after that I didn't
really want Lebaran cemetery anymore
understandably yeah and you know so I
mean he said I read an interview with
him and you know he said the insurance
investigators came and they could not
find any arson they couldn't find any
reason for it or I bet he said it wasn't
me I promise ok well it was like I was
burned down my own chan avi judged a man
- yeah that he's just really skilled I
mean he might be committed man I don't
know it's like I'm gonna burn my own jet
down I know how they work I know how to
do this yeah right by the water heater
but um so like I said oh and also this
is not super relevant but they said that
in 2004 they actually arrested like two
teenage boys who had broken into the
tomb stolen a skull and we're kicking it
around like a soccer ball okay okay
there's a contributing bit of evidence
yeah there's a lot of shenanigans going
on and tomfoolery
going on it gives a dad I get worried
mom foolery going on inside SM and
jiggery-pokery I agree that may have
actually inspired the creation of this
case although like I said yes because I
mean these two kids got caught in 2004
maybe that's why they roped off the
cemetery no no no B I don't know that it
was roped up in 1998 maybe it started
all the way back there in 98 yeah maybe
people might have been just because of
the shekinah Reid yes I was actually
gonna say that whatever baby do it ever
since the guy versus for almost 500
reports and they keep they keep a
detailed log if you go on the tour and
some bad happens to you you get hit or
you pass out or you throw up or you get
a broken fingers that's also a very
commonly reportable wave a whole lot
your cameras are a bit now hold on are
these broken fingers confirmed
I don't know all I saw was the reporter
what do the paper reported reported I
thought some fiction - some x-rays mr.
Berger by speaking if we can get a
confirmed broken finger out of there
doctors and everything okay
maybe even on sinew I would give this a
little more credit points see here is
what's killing me though because if this
is something paranormal like okay I'm
not as weirded out by the whole
paranormal it's like Oh something
scratched me another scratches on your
back how like how bridges break your
finger you just be standing there you
know I minding your own business and
then all of a sudden ah how did you
handle this case in the book when you
wrote about I basically like I said it
much like your hand on it now basically
well I'm not laughing at whoa cause like
I said in the book I just I just wrote
down I said I wrote down the [__] that
people said they don't know all right
that's all that's all you can really do
that's I mean I wasn't like editorialize
did I give an opinion after not on that
particular run down all right I said
this is what so I said ever since people
on the tours people go on the tours now
a lot of people follow the tours and
nothing happened right
okay but it's it's often enough and they
say sometimes they'll be like you know a
few weeks or a month or something where
nothing really happens like a record and
then suddenly they'll be like a flurry
okay like they'll have a tour group and
like a couple people will pass out and
the person will have to get bit or
something like that
or they'll hear some [__] some people
have taken pictures and there's like
weird like light anomalies like you're
on of the [__] light and it's not all
just like weird like ghosty looking
things
okay well you know I think you know our
regular lights you will know that you
know I am NOT a disbeliever I have
actually seen real paranormal phenomenon
before in in the form of traditional
culture Geist or classic poltergeist in
terms of you know like what a pair of
psychologists would say which is you
know basically our SDK so I'm not a
disbeliever
but I'm automatically skeptical of any
kind of tours not a surge of this one
any tour
I'm skeptical any of these haunted hotel
skeptical because they have a reason do
ya there's a reason for it doesn't
necessarily mean it's rush it and that
doesn't necessarily mean I'm saying this
guy's full of [__] I wouldn't go to no
hell no I'd go on that tour I'd go on
that tour just cuz I'm curious yeah I
would say yeah I want to under like the
plus I
I got to say that the great Friars
kirkyard is gorgeous yeah I would love
to go see it if this is if this is a
hoax and it's a profitable business and
then kudos to the duty you know and I
generally made a good story is the story
enough where I'd like to go see I
probably I suddenly want to go to the
creepy we gift shop yeah but um I want
to go just to see if that floors busted
out beside that mob win but again you
they got that door chef well yeah I
don't know if they let you actually go
inside but it's not very big like the
tomb is the other thing it's not like
you're thinking like no no I just like
the one on the stepheson album cuz it's
like those don't yeah it's not that bad
you now here's something that you might
find interesting because I know like you
know you and me we kind of talked about
what could cause poltergeist activity
basically even though they said now the
Paranormal Activity allegedly didn't
start until you know the tomb was broken
into so leading some people to believe
that it's a ghost going quote like an
angry ghost but sit but see most of the
activity that's reported is very
poltergeist like now it's not a
poltergeist situation right because it's
been going on for years it's been going
on a lot of interactive haunting right
but here's here's the thing and you
might find this interesting because I
don't think I've ever heard anyone that
sells if it's a real this is an
interactive honk yeah because I don't
think I've ever heard anyone espouse
this particular theory about poltergeist
causation before and actually now I
should add this to the book that's
because I never heard this before ever
but apparently and apparently the people
like the tour guides will will say this
on the tour because the like I said the
houses around the around the tomb also
have some poltergeist activity and
people that have been on the tour said
that the [__] followed them back home
like when they got back home or when
they got back to their hotels
light bulbs would explode that kind of
[__] pull down like the lauded mansion
it di right right yeah off all your
heart okay but like I said so they said
somebody came up I think it was Alan
gall maybe who I think I mentioned in my
book in another case he came up with the
theory that poltergeist activity is
related to human pheromones
have you ever heard that theory before I
don't think we'd ever talk about no
never heard of because I was kind of I
was thinking maybe related to mass
psychology maybe like a group of people
might get psychically teed up and
actually yeah they have they have yes
people have floated that idea I never
thought of the idea that I think and
actually in a way I think they're kind
of saying the same thing like people
pheromones are mixing in weird ways and
they and also they said they said this
might explain why poltergeist activity
tends to happen around adolescence with
a bunch of with a bunch of yeah and
stuff like that I was how am I not right
and I always thought there was a groups
energy behind it but I didn't think I
don't think had any to the hormones but
or pheromones yeah in terms of what
citylink
pheromone right maybe pheromones and
hormones coming out of the actual
adolescent yeah but you know I never
never thought of it that way I don't
have to see it I have to see some
Navitus yeah cuz they said well that
would explain why poltergeist activity
like I said generally happens around
adolescence and also why why in this
particular case it supposedly follows
people home like certainly followed
people home like maybe some people are
like Sarah modally you know predisposed
of poltergeist falling around I don't
know but that I've actually never heard
that but different interpretation of
what hypothesis all of what I've said
and what that's right a mellow I thought
I would venture like I'll just have said
going back to the 50s because you know
it's just a play on that and almost kind
of like somebody regurgitating a
misunderstanding oh yeah this yes well
because like I said there was actually a
paper I think it was in 2004 and I think
I mentioned this in this book because
there was a paper in a journal called
neuro-oncology
and they've a positive that to go rip up
this okay damn it men against did it
muggers why is the joke okay but he
isn't taking office lugar okay but um
yeah so in this paper they said a
similar thing they said that that maybe
when adolescents go through puberty yes
if there's some kind of like weird
electron fluctuations in the brain that
can cause effects outside of the body
for a brief period sake so that's almost
like saying it's
I just never heard anything so typically
mentioned pheromones just a more
prettier with yeah that's just a more
primitive description of dr. Hameroff
you know quantum soul yeah Cemil that's
all that simple it's just different way
of describing that same fact it's the
same thing I'm saying yeah so something
I thought I'd mentioned pheromones
because I never heard that mentioned I
think hormonal imbalances and stretches
stressors and things like that could
actually cause this condition where you
know that some kind of subatomic
particles you know on the Planck scale
you know quantum particles can somehow
in a interact with other quantum
particles at a distance in the same way
you have spooky action at a distance
but the wonder really now I'm not the
one to answer that debby debby Stuart
Hameroff job to describe that that can
be pretty complicated anyway anybody who
says tells you that they understand
quantum physics is a line that guys
would ever stand quantum physics don't
understand quantum physics well it's
just it's not our brains are not really
uh really evolved to understand that
type of thing because that's not how we
perceive how the world around us how one
particle can be in two different places
at the same time you know that's not
where we're not built to understand that
but you know space and time of the
space-time continuum is not as real as
we think it is yeah or not linear I mean
like I said up ausa
okay now if if we're saying that the
black mausoleum if there is something
like sort of paranormal going on there I
almost find it more like I don't think
it's a ghost or nothing like that I
almost think it's more interesting that
all of the people going there like
expecting to see something right much it
might somehow be able to I don't know
like almost feel like the catalyst for
something happening like you've got many
people wanting something I mean you
think that that might be some kind of
affect my default daddy especially when
it comes with things like tours like I
said for tours and haunted hotels
my default setting is skepticism my help
my habit I have to see it myself
yeah that's your mother and you know I'd
like to go and see yeah I would because
like I said you know once they have a
tour in
like that is kind of incentive so I type
it out or oh it's the most dangerous
older guys you're going to get bit
you're going to get standard I don't
understand don't get experienced and
when you sell an experience like that
who knows you might have some chicanery
and tomfoolery and all the things they
do over there and don't forget the
jiggery-pokery to do that happen I have
some of that mixed with maybe some mass
hysteria and psychosomatic I yeah
manifestation cuz that's kind of a sad
thing about this even be kind of not in
a control environment yeah you know Oh
something bit me oh really something
[__] award and we get that down you
know you can't really prove it that's
what I mean so well touched me and
that's yeah and that's why I'm really
right that I I really can't get down
with those go Turner show and stuff like
that because it's all oh did you hear
that did you smell that and he's like no
I'm not there dude I can't you know
something watch me it's like there's no
and it always tends to be some kind of
young lady who doesn't normally get
touched it was her saying I know unless
me I wish some I would hardly touch okay
yeah let me just send me down a pathway
Oh darkness I thought you said
retardedness a yeah what's [__] have
we pretty much covered this now I think
so yeah oh yeah it works okay we're
almost to that yeah yeah okay so anyway
what were you going to say at the end
now I forgot I was gonna day yeah I
gotta go see it go check it out yeah I
actually want to it looks pretty cool
yeah even if even if I'm evil but I was
like listen even if I don't get but
marked by a ghost no you know it would
still I brought up by working yeah yeah
yeah we made it when we were out when we
were in high school playing a video game
called rats and it has like a Conan the
Barbarian game but they're running and
jumping calling Mario had fall into the
pit or just spikes over there it was
laying on is very glass on the - a
friend of mine says mega court because
it makes me weird so now to this day
like every to this but everything is fun
working yes I know
now you guys can use that for that's I'm
going to hashtag I don't remember that
Bible I don't remember the exact time
effect rest and would make when he lands
on but maybe one of our I remember
really find a soundbite with this I'm
sure you can yes yes Fleming feller he
does appoint you to does everybody yeah
so anyway okay alright so my gosh am i
right
yeah so we're going to get to the end of
the show and let's see one of what do I
usually say don't forget to go and check
the project centers name and remember
sure cool shirt yeah yeah we got a new
shirt you just didn't go today
yeah I just did a new logo shirt it's
kind of some one of the other one but
it's kind of like a different kind of
vibe going on and that is going to be
available on the project Entertainment
Network Shore and Jenny's wearing the
satanic panic shirt right this moment
yeah right this moment to you know we
just make our own cool t-shirts huh
that's right I just make my own [__]
[__] make my own clothes well I'll make
them I was right I was running around
the shirt mean you want yeah yeah a
little the logo says you know broken
glass that was so funny you were that
wall during the other day of the lady
behind the counter would let you guys
you guys yeah I get it
and I said we don't even look at you and
you were you had shaved your head
involved is it something you didn't even
look as much like you but she feel right
now I'm grown the hair back a little bit
though yeah I guess I decided I like the
hair better you look good boss you know
I think I'm gonna die that blonde you
know really look like something awful
Duran Duran you're gonna get Duran Duran
again I like the blonde hair okay
seriously so anyway yeah go to the
project Entertainment Network their
patreon and got a close look at her my
mascara on yeah do it
ah it's alright I won't tell anybody
I'll wear to the club we talking about
yeah but anyway yeah what am I wrong
mascara
what that's not okay alright okay well
uh-oh
musical interlude since this is about
graveyard I do now is just wait okay
don't ask just wait
all right well not even tell anybody
worried so I surprise them with it okay
all surprising there be a surprise okay
and if you liked the show
remember go follow us on Twitter go like
our Facebook page blah blah blah yeah
you know how that goes in this okay it's
the end of the show and come back next
week for another rambling [__]
session gotta go gotta go see you next
week bye
[Music]
Jonah does so I'll meet you at the
summit you guys guys I'm sure sighs I
said a sunny day no one
and again
yes sir on your side why
[Music]